in the heart of Los Angeles this is
screen junkies movie fights
Andi signor today's episode is presented
by t-mobile America's best unlimited
network
hello screen junkies I am NOT your host
and ignore is on vacation I am Dan
Merrill I'm hosting today's show welcome
back we were at comic-con for a week
we're back we're live here on YouTube
live movie fights how fun is that and we
have some great fights for you today
including what actors should get their
own take in style franchise oh pitch a
title for the next James Bond movie
we're hearing more about that and this
is one of my favorites I can't wait to
hear these pitch a worse idea than the
emoji movie that should be a lot of fun
if you want to join the conversation you
can go live on Twitter hashtag movie
fights live and if you're watching the
live on YouTube I hear that there's an
infinitely fast scrolling bar taxi to
jump into why not I remind you though we
are live this week we are gonna be going
live every single week however we do
have one last bit of comic-con business
to wrap-up so where I could be live next
week and you'll still be on vacation and
we had a all-star episode at San Diego
comic-con we showed you the Elijah Wood
Kevin Smith fight last week that was
super fun we also did an all-star panel
at comic-con in San Diego that we're
going to bring to you next Thursday here
at four o'clock so we will be here next
Thursday however we're gonna be showing
you our comic-con panel it was super fun
Spencer was there Alecia Malone Benson
lots of fun people were there so check
that out next week and then two weeks
from today we'll be back here live on
YouTube and every week after that with
movie fights so before we get into the
show of course we want to meet our great
panel of fighters I was lucky enough to
get to judge today and kind of weigh in
on who I wanted to be on the show and I
think this is a great roster first of
all he's no stranger to this show he is
the master of the speed round coins on
show coins
welcome back first Youtube show yes it's
even higher I feel it I feel the
internet watching you know that live in
Toronto they're giving me speed and
power she made her debut on the show
earlier this year and she has proven
herself to be a fierce competitor
Charlie Feldman welcome back I put on
pants
well Charlie welcome to the show I'm so
happy that you joined us and this is
tough for me to say he's in the Champs
chair he is the current movie fights
champion who I guess now the champion
gets to fight this is not a belt match
and I guess the champion gets to fight
now
Spencer yo I'll put the belt on anytime
anyplace well right now I think anyway
that would be too much of a conflict of
interesting I want you to look at my
competition today yeah but it's not real
till I beat I don't think me judging
about fighting over the belt would be
viewed as an impartial observer so mail
buyer down I'm tempted but I'm gonna say
no and filling it for me on the
fact-checking couch the game master
himself Juan Harris lon how's it going
going pretty good yeah I look forward to
the emails we'd all get if we decided to
randomly put the belt on that I think
Andy would fly back first of all the
studio if we did a belt fight it's my
belt I can do what I want to learn if
they learn all the Scandinavian curse
words he's like the things that I care
mom IKEA jump into round 1 I do want to
say something we love that we are live
now every single week on YouTube
Thursdays 4 p.m. Pacific time and the
reason why we're able to do that is that
we have a great partner and sponsor and
t-mobile not only are they bringing you
movie fights live on YouTube every week
they sponsors screen junkies central
last week in San Diego or week before
last in San Diego which was amazing they
did last year's screen Jackie central as
well we were able to have a great party
both times where the great event you
just watch the Kevin Smith Elijah Wood
fight that was because they helped us
out with that entire event also TV
fights is on screen junkies news now
every week on Tuesdays movie fights here
live watching Thrones with Spencer is
there live every Monday on trailer
commentaries is over on news every
Wednesday and they are all free on
YouTube every week instead of behind the
paywall because t-mobile's helping us
out with that so we want to thank you
t-mobile
we could not do these shows and bring
them to you in front of the paywall
without their help and support so watch
all those shows on screen junkies and
screen junkies news and Thank You
t-mobile for helping us bring those out
to the public because I think people
really been enjoying what they've seen
so far we look forward to brick keeping
on bringing it to you guys so before we
go into the game just a quick reminder
this is not just based on your answers
this is based on your arguments all
scoring is based on the facts presented
on passion and on creativity any
questions before we start you're all
veterans let's do it let's do this
that 10 fights
nice I like that like check it's very
dramatic
all right guys round one there's a Halle
Berry movie coming out called kidnap
this pretty said it's not gonna light
it's not gonna like Catwoman s character
there's also a trailer Eli we're also
doing a remake of Death Wish with Bruce
Willis so there's a lot of revenge
thriller type things going on in the
news right now so we thought it'd be fun
to ask what actor actors who doesn't
have one already
should get their own taken style action
franchise Liam Neeson kind of
reinvigorated this whole genre back with
taken you can really build something
around one of these personalities you to
find an actor actress that doesn't have
one of these that you think would do
well and coy you're in this you're in
the first chair you start us off so when
I think incredible franchise and when I
think action star and I think revenge
plot and when I think charismatic but
dastardly and intense I think the only
man that can act with one eyeball Tom
Hardy this man is so interesting every
movie he's in he doesn't have to talk
this man does nothing wrong and the only
time we had a lighter action movie
starring him it just so happened to be a
rom-com so we need to fix that
the only smidge on his otherwise
beautiful resume this man needs a
franchise where he gets to be an action
star in a more traditional linear way
we've had him do great things and
intellectual action films like
interstellar and and inception we've had
him do brilliant things with Mad Max we
haven't had him in a full-blown 80 /
early nineties revenge thriller
there's a reason payback is so good it's
because Mel Gibson was the action star
then you know who the new Mel Gibson is
now Tom Hardy he needs this franchise
great guy Tom hood
Charlie who's your pay all agree on that
so when I think of a taken franchise I
think about a new opportunity for an
actor that hasn't really shown what they
got Liam Neeson everyone pegged him as a
certain type of actor a dramatic actor
shouldn't lives list sort of actor but
they don't really look at him and think
action movie dark man notwithstanding so
when I think about the actresses I would
like to see kick some butt and take name
I would never live I don't know if I
could say yeah action stars who
absolutely needs to come back who had
the guns and ready to use them and
that's Linda Hamilton Linda Hamilton
Sarah Connor herself is ready for that
comeback she was out we need to bring
her back in she's at that age where she
can really bring the gravitas to a
character royal where her someone has
abducted probably her child and she has
to go out of her way to help and find it
and use her set of skills and her set of
skills as being the best mom to ever be
in any sort of film franchise and on top
of that in my research I learned that
she's been dealing with bipolar disorder
and I feel like it'd be a good thing to
put out there that people who have
mental illness can still lead franchises
to the top and she's the one to do it
she's a badass Hamilton Sarah Connor
returns Spencer guys there's only one
answer it's Jacob the tiny terror
Tremblay I mean look at that killer he
is the last person you'd ever expect to
be a highly trained assassin and that to
me is the joy of a taken style movie is
something like taken with Liam Neeson or
John wick with Keanu or even earlier
with Bourne and Damon where you're like
I did not realize that person kicks ass
that's that's where I want out of these
movies I want my job to drop to be so
surprised when some actor who I don't
think of as a killer slices someone
throats someone's throat off Oren Jacob
Tremblay --zz case may be biting
someone's balls off or jumping out of a
steam vent to kill somebody I think that
he would be such a shock and it'd be so
awesome to see a killer kid movie and I
think he's the perfect one to do it
alright guys so we have this is not this
is not I'm gonna be honest is not the
lineup I had mine
we have Tom Hardy Linda Hamilton and
Jacob Tremblay so many directions to go
fight it out you guys I've seen home
alone three and I'm still a babies like
that sense and they never felt right Spy
Kids didn't work and it doesn't work now
I know we are living in a child murderer
Renaissance what's in it definitely keen
and people love that hit girl Chloe
grace Moretz there's another one he
doesn't he's this mop but he's adorable
these are gonna have the grub that's
what it's the surprise factor I know
what are you getting from Leon Hamilton
I'm getting Sarah Connor but old you
just listed two rates of having
characters those supporting characters
he didn't carry a franchise he just did
that
awful teletraan choices that Tom Hardy's
carries Shirley's Thrones but he's gonna
do carnage as well just to say that he
has franchises that he's carrying right
now he doesn't need you he's about
nothing that he doesn't carry those
franchises he rides on the franchise's
coattails he shows up with Christopher
Nolan be like hey key put me another
great man have you seen any of the
things that's loves they're fine but
like Tom Hardy's solo movies that come
on Trevor a movie that dress this kid
just did was not even because they can't
spoiler alert he dives in like the first
time so this kid does not carry a movie
and he get predator that's gonna be
great for him and maybe then we can see
it but this kid is not something we need
that's not something I'd go see and have
you know not see Jacob Tremblay busting
out of a steam vent and biting an
Eastern Europeans balls play it straight
it's one numbers and larry's it's a
funny idea but it's not something that
people gonna show up for it and really
like be into it because it's spike it's
not fun it's not as interesting as Linda
Hamilton who we haven't seen in a while
we haven't see what she's fully capable
of it because the only role she's known
for Sarah Connor have you won't always
be comparing her to Sarah Connor
was really known for what Schindler's
List for the most part not talking about
everyone boy Liam Neeson was the guy in
the eighties that showed up and I go
sorry wasn't still taken the people took
him as a different but I have you shoot
me nicely a Sunday horse law school or
perhaps Bermuda tentacles because that
was 2015-2017 s Linda Hamilton run those
are five movies capability to be a star
as you show turns their back on women
humor of a certain age everybody knows
we were offenders supporting Weaver
Gainesville imperative are you could
give me outliers but that's not the
usual thing Helen or you can give me
that button Linda Hamelin Dutch Helen
Mirren a second this new role because
it's something we haven't seen from her
in a long time she deserves to carry I'm
sorry she very clearly peaked decided
for her and she would come back to K by
your the tentacles decided it for her
perhaps a Sunday horse to say I want to
see someone who has the balls secede
Linda Hamilton and be like I remember a
Sarah Connor and I know she can carry a
felony she doesn't have the on page you
see guns and where's the guns now
Charlie Neeson can bulk up so can Linda
Hamilton your guys are gonna put Helen
Mirren and she's ready now I love this
hell of an idea you're putting things
against her that don't exist she has the
capability she can get trainers to bulk
up that's not you got a lean into it you
got a make her an older mom character
for it to cool in there you have to make
him ferocious Brosius and sometimes the
least inspired choice possible it's like
oh we're making like a gritty revenge
action movie let's get the grumbly guy
we get the guy who can actually act and
do the revenge this guy can do actions
you see drama
does really interesting action
I feel like kidnap movies they're
already at a certain point in your
career where you don't like you can't
get any other saying it doesn't deserve
better guys you guys said we can't get
into the role she can get a role like
this and blow it out of the park because
no one has these expectations for it
sounds like a direct-to-dvd wait what
I'm a better you just above the
franchise buddy they've touched on any
kind of interesting relationship that
your character his parents its
kidnapping children clearly the the
Halle Berry one they've kidnapped our
daughter
what if we reverse it what if it's oh my
god the parents are gone but they messed
with the wrong kid
that's an interesting premise whereas
you are just doing generic action movies
ditching us home alone but now there's
like this is what I miss from the show I
do want to kind of stretch it a little
bit Spencer which with Tremblay I mean
we're talking are we talking like
Tremblay are we talking this is hard art
this is like hip girl this is like Logan
this is a kid murdering p.m. this is
action this is played straight this
isn't like goofy there will be funny
parts were like the Hitman comes her
henchman comes over like are you okay
kid and he's like damn right I'm okay
and just pulls out a shotgun and stuff
like that they it will be played for
jokes at times but the tone is gonna be
yeah it'll be like taking or John wick
like this is at his core he's a scared
kid who misses his dad but on the
outside he's a trained stone-cold killer
okay Charlie I'm curious Linda Hamilton
movie what's that what is the feel that
you are doing what Hollywood did they
are under selling her and undervaluing
what she brings to rolls she I've seen
her in t2 we've all seen her in t2 but
we've also seen her in Beauty and the
Beast she has this range where she can
be sensitive she can be badass she has
this ability about her and just because
Hollywood looked at her and look at her
mental illness and they're like no she's
out we're not interested in her I'm not
gonna do that I see her and I see a star
that needs to be up in lights again this
is her time she's paid her dues she
deserves
show what she has and that's strength of
will cuz Sarah Connor went and she
mustn't have been Terminator 1 and
Terminator 2 especially as her made her
- and she'll do it again those guns are
under I know those middle-aged lady like
flaps they're under there yeah visioning
Tom Hardy's took on this I love the idea
of his wife and son being taken I love
it even more the family taken too and
yeah but the taken to the problem was it
rehashed the first one I want to
actually see something transcend the
medium like you were saying like Tom
Hardy's better than this I want to see
you can Ben movie I actually go see I
didn't see taken to it and see taken
through it and see taken on a plane or
whatever it was called I like I want to
see a kidnap movie like it was in the
eighties like I think payback is a
really good movie I think movies then
when they cared about Brit and I
actually wrote the story world matters
so I want to see Tom Hardy because he
would make the movie better and he would
demand the script be better I want to
see something where it's better than the
medium not something that's
direct-to-dvd or I mean there's a reason
we haven't seen her in 20 years that
might not just be the system the
system's broken
everyone knows the system's broken but
we also don't have any counter point
beyond Stephenie 80 she might be
actually someone that can't work and I
don't know if I want to see Tremblay do
anything that feels like home alone
because there's a reason they stopped
making those movies and the reason
there's no place for it and that movie
sounds tone-deaf like if it's sometimes
serious sometimes funny it doesn't seem
to have a place and without knowing
where she stands the only one of these
that I could see actually selling and
being interested and being better than
the movie of Halle Berry coming out this
weekend is Tom Hardy Spencer give me one
last just take on Tremblay and why you
think it's gonna overcome the negative
points that these guys have brought up
well I think that there's moments of
humor in all of these movies even John
wick there's like moments where you go
haha alright cool but this is a
throwback action movie and it's but it's
also a twist on it where you don't
expect you're not getting Tom Hardy a
gruff guy looking out for revenge you
see say it's like a new twist on the 80s
and he's elevating material it sounds
like every other revenge movie and yours
pitching little Linda Hamilton and you
even called her Sarah Connor in your
description of it she has she's always
going to be compared and fall short of
that iconic role Tremblay he's young
it's exciting we are loving to watch
children murder people right now let's
seize the
and give it to the tiny tear we're from
the headlines any fact checks any any
corrections - - Utah - to fact checks
Tom already not in the interstellar and
fixing the best of my knowledge and
Jacob trembley's character does not die
in book of Henry mild spoilers it's
there's another kid who dies in book of
Henry yes I don't believe it's the
giblets trigger Oh YouTube commenters
Twitter are loving the fact that we're
in a child murderer and love it that's
the takeaway there's also a lot of love
for Charlie's Flamingo shirt and some of
the other suggestions Nicolas Cage
probably the number one suggestion uma
Thurman came up very frequently Natalie
Portman came up a lot and an odd one
michael cera we got a lot of well here's
how I see it
Charlie I think you got knocked out that
not only because the main thing was that
I in your argument I just felt like you
just wanted 1992 with the Hamilton back
and you kept just kind of referring to
like we've seen terminator and we've
seen Beauty even reference Beauty and
the Beast and I just didn't hear enough
about why right now she would be the
best choice out of the three so I had to
knock Lemmon Linda Hamilton out which
took me between coy and Spencer and you
know Spencer when you answered I was
like god that's a joke answer and I'm
still not sure if it really is my
problem is coy didn't Spencer
particularly brought at this point of
like coy you didn't really sell me about
Tom Hardy like why would him doing this
transcend what we've seen already and I
think Spencer kind of hammered you on
that and you didn't really sell me on
why Tom Hardy's particularly would be
any different or any better so strangely
you know I thought this is the one that
was gonna go
spencer sold me the most on why jacob
xxx will be the most interesting and
creativity council Spencer I'm giving
you the point of you yes I have to polls
so if you're in YouTube and you want to
vote you've got to refresh the video and
then you've got to turn off annotations
to turn the back on or either simple
there there are people voting right now
51% of the YouTube viewers went with Tom
Hardy 34% for Jacob Tremblay only 13%
they should well one day I agree with
you Charlie that they there is a
systemic problem in Hollywood
particularly that political on
innovation let's move on to round two
we're starting to hear more and more
about the next James Bond movie bond 25
right right line bonded 21 2015 yeah we
made we're getting reports that Daniel
Craig will be back but it's not
confirmed confirmed that he's going to
definitely be back but the one that we
can talk about is the title there's been
speculation that it's going to be called
shatterhand which I'm not so sure about
but we can't ask what did you guys do
pitching me a title for the next James
Bond film that would be the 25th Bond
film and why do you think it should be
called that Charlie I'm gonna start with
you in this round next Bond movie what
do you think the title should be next
Bond movie so other than say Doctor Who
there's been no long-running
most archetypal British character than
James Bond so I want to bring it to a
very British angle but also a reflection
on where we've been we're 25 years so we
have a lot of reflection to do about
this character and also where England is
right now because England's in a very
precarious interesting place where their
billion brexit was good or not
so I feel the movie should be called the
Sun never sets and if you don't know
what that means is the Sun never sets on
the British Empire meaning that there's
so much the Empire Britain the big sort
of gobbled up all these countries
but the Sun literally will never set
because it's always up in one of their
territories countries and places so with
bond the Sun will never set on this
franchise this character because it is
an iconic character a very iconic
British character that will go on for
the ages so when I want to see a next
Bond 'some I want to see the energy of
that I want to look to the past while
looking to the future the franchise I
deeply hope it's not Daniel Craig
because he's totally dead behind the
eyes I want to be a new Bond
maybe Idris I don't know I want to see
someone who really delights in it
because right now the Kingsmen is
bringing all the fun to the British spy
movie I want to see that back to bond
alright the Sun never sets on James Bond
Spencer what was your choice I wanted to
kind of tie it in with previous James
Bond's which is something that they
don't usually do but this we've been
getting a different kind of bond out of
Craig these movies have been very
connected from one to the other so I
want to call mine downfall it refers to
Skyfall in that this is I think we can
say Daniel Craig's last one is that
correct that he's just got but he'd only
signed on for one it was barely and we
need reassurance that this is the last
one we need to know that this is it for
Daniel Craig bits this thing that began
Casino Royale and then quantum solace
whatever but like Skyfall Spectre
downfall we need something that tells us
there's gonna be some sense of finality
to this arc because they've actually
been doing like a long term multiple
movie arc with this James Bond we need
some closure on it alright downfall from
Spencer coy what is your eye time into
the anniversary concept it's the 25th
one I want my title to feel like that's
importance
like I love anniversary I love 2500
fifty I like I love those things they
feel right and I wanted to tie into not
only the idea that you have where it
ties in to where he is and it's hanging
into the same franchise and I'm going to
Daniel Craig idea but also the idea that
it's eternal men at bed it's um that
lasts forever so I went with too young
to die which also has a flavour of only
the good die young I mean it's got a
flavour of like where the mysticism of
bond was when we started with Spectre
where where all the flavor of the bond
is and the last two movies were all
about
how old Daniel Craig was like he's got
like this thing where he's like I can't
be but it was weird because they gave
him an orange movie where he was already
saying he was too old so we keep going
through this iteration of James Daniel
Craig where he keeps like adjusting is
but he's getting harder than he's having
trouble doing it so I love the idea that
we settle in it's also Daniel Craig's
last movie we're too young to die is is
it where it wraps up its got that
interesting like Quantum of Solace you
wondered what it was Spectre you wonder
what was I like the title having some
inquisitiveness to it and I feel like
this is a good closure for Daniel
Craig's bump alright so we have two
young to die the Sun never sets and
downfall what are you guys tonight skew
young he's not too she's quite he's
quite but it's not a play on anything
because he doesn't reflect that he is an
older man and he's at the end of his
career as bond if this is a Daniel Craig
movie so too young to die seems
meaningless I know it's on my brain
right now but it makes me think of child
murder it's gonna be really bad like you
said it's cool James Bond titles are
cool because they make you wonder and
downfall to me makes me wonder oh is he
going to die is this gonna be the last
James Bond we all know it's not but at
least it raises questions like that in
your head yours look me smart he did not
know what you were talking about with
the Sun never sets on the British Empire
people are gonna have to look that up
because when I hear it I think like it's
an Enrique Iglesias song like it sounds
like something that secret-service on
his majesty and then other sort of very
emblematic rich think it sounds like
sparks novel in this Sun never sets it's
like a far beyond cover titles from
early a bum with downfall I really like
where your head's out I like that it's a
continuation of things but sky falls in
the middle of Craig's franchise but that
was the bomb you want to gun fires about
where he comes from childhood home best
of all them and he started off it
started you with Vesper Lynd it started
you with how this this bond reacted to
the rest of the franchise going out so
if you want to start you start with the
scene around maybe the house winds would
be a better setup
so I actually emailed the I said the
wrong thing just now but you can check
my email to my actual title is too old
to die young that's an awesome Paris
right but but that would be fine
so my actually any took me I said it
wrong yeah I meant to say that instead
of too young to die I said Mike gonna
like hang a lantern on how old is wanted
to be so Mike my plot was so I'm sorry
for the first 10 second well Sean
Connery did like she was way too old so
too old to die young the idea is that
he's going into more than m lake state
he's actually turning into like he's
actually giving the responsibility he's
realizing he's becoming it's a bond that
takes accountability right so the thing
I made the first movie so interesting is
that he was a bond that was kind of
accountable the second movie when they
introduced Rafi they made him
accountable there's always that thing
where bond doesn't actually interesting
for me so the inquisitiveness it's a
plan it's not cool to be cool it's a
deeply negative space to take the last
potential Craig yeah you go into a we
failed because the downfall of you sound
followed what is whereas I want to see
the Sun never sets that's an optimistic
glance at the future of the franchise
whether you have Daniel Craig going on
just represent or you have a new bond
taking up the reins and showing you what
the franchise is girl already bummed out
that Daniel Craig is coming back down
fall these gives me hope she's gonna be
killed up if this will be the end so as
much as mines might sound like an Austin
Powers title the Sun never sets
exactly sounds like Tomorrow Never Dies
and Tomorrow Never Dies is the worst
James Bond movie like one of the worst
at anything that's not never sets
Tomorrow Never but it literally sounds
like an attenuation of eternity which is
what the James Bond movies feel like
right now but it's not just an eternity
even if you were if I were to extend
that it's about Britain it's about
England it's
in the colonial era like in this 1700
yes their past just like bond has a past
that people are fairly you know feel bad
because it was like how are you treats
women but I'm not getting into that it
doesn't really matter because what I'm
talking about is the future of where
bonds going and where England's going
and this is the movie that can reflect
that I think your ancient history know
you name it in a reflection of the past
that looks towards the future because
it's a deeply optimistic phrase and it's
it's a jungle Sun never sets on the
British Empire the franchise has been
optimistic anymore the franchise is what
started Roger Moore was a more fun bond
we have tons of fun bun right I think
their time we've already had the dark
and gritty we're done with that Daniel
Craig did a bang-up job yeah now we go
back to for yours no I want to get
through just because I think we got some
other great fights so I wanna get to so
I think that's a great close your
statement Spencer I want to hear your
why down fallen why not these two okay
yeah down fall we want some finality I
think it fits with the rest of the
Daniel Craig movies in that there has
been way more continuation from movie to
movie than we've gotten with Connery's
bond or more bond so why not have
continuation in the titles or play with
the titles that have come before it also
lets you know that it's over the Sun
never sets sounds like like a Fabio
cover book in a supermarket and it also
sends to sunny for bond the Sun is never
up on Daniel Craig's James Bond alright
and quite for me and now that I have my
own title right too old to die young not
only makes you wonder what the movies
about it gives you a sense of finality
it gives me all the things that I get
from what you guys are saying it gives
you a finality the bomb without saying
it's a ninety Super Snake Album it gives
me a interesting like phrase that makes
you want to play with it I can see it on
the poster but at the same time when I
think the Sun never sets I agree we're
living in a John wick Jason Bourne era
that's where the bond is right now like
Kingsman is that for a reason that's
separate if James Bond something went
Kingsman it would feel like they were
copying Kingsman and that franchise is
way too like important to feel like a
copycat and downfall if I see that on a
poster that sounds like a rotten
tomatoes like buzzword for how bad the
movie is so neither of these titles
inspire me
is too old to die young makes me wonder
makes me feel like it's part of a
franchise and it describes the arc of
where Daniel Craig Bond is going it has
been alright there we go one a lot of
people did point out that the Sun never
sets was used by a lot of empires to
express that they're so vast that
they're all around the world so it's not
necessarily just British although the
Sun never sets on the British Empire was
a common expression and we got a lot of
clever I thought suggested titles a
shaken not stirred atomic bond
double-oh-seven in New York Gold's bond
bond versus Bourne and double owned
nothing I'm not gonna lie this was a
fairly easy decision for me I think coy
even though even once you got the title
right I think they kind of got you on
the it does sound it's here you're
really it seems like a downer already
you're describing the franchise
negatively already Spencer between that
and the Sun never sets I just I think
that again like you they kind of hit you
a little bit unlike it seems like you're
already describing the failure even said
like oh we're getting ahead of the bad
reviews so I actually like Charlie's
take on it I know that you said the Dana
Craig doesn't it's not optimistic but
Charlie Center arrogant that it wasn't
gonna be Daniel Craig which I can allow
and also I think it's just the way that
it ties in with the British Empire with
the anniversary I think that it was the
best pitch for why I tied in with James
Bond specifically so I'm gonna go with
Charlie Charlie gets the point in round
2 I will say Spencer I'm shocked and
nobody brings it out that I would not
have I would have not chosen downfall
because all you would get is Hitler
memes if you start 72
[Music]
doesn't matter so Charlie gets the point
Charlie and Spencer you're tied at1 but
we're only in round three
the trailer for ready player one came
out at Comic Con a lot of people I liked
it's kind of got a lot of people buzzing
if you don't know ready player one takes
place in this thing called the Oasis and
it's basically and it's not really a
game but you have your avatar and you
can upgrade so we thought if ready
player one was real what movie character
would you want to use as your avatar so
this is the character that you are
playing as in the game slash Oasis world
this is the person you would want to
represent you you're controlling them
Spencer we're going to start with you
who would be your avatar I'm racist I'm
gonna go with a personal favorite of
mine Jean Baptiste Emmanuelle zorg Gary
Oldman from the Fifth Element
I'd love to they could bring a picture
up so we could see his sweet plastic
comb-over and his sweet soul patch and
his awesome clothes he's I just think
he's cool it's Gary Oldman right off the
bat so you sound and look like Gary
Oldman you got that kind of swagger to
you he's rich he's a he's the head of a
giant conglomerate and as we've seen
from the books or whatever the Oasis is
not a classless society there are
definite haves and have-nots like the
hero can't even get off is free to play
school island until he does some stuff
he's got the zf1 the gun from the Fifth
Element which is the coolest movie gun
of all time it's got the the replay
system it's got the flamethrower it's
got the rocket launchers got the ice
cube system the patented ice cube system
the net it's got the little red button
on it it's awesome he's got one of those
and he's a deep nerd reference he's not
like an obvious oh I'm gonna be Frodo or
I'm gonna be Luke Skywalker cuz ready
player one is all about like what are
the cool nerd references that not
everyone would realize but someone be
like oh you're zorg from the fifth
element that's cool from the fifth
element coy who would you pick as your
avatar I chose a character that can fly
that is hard to defeat that is
constantly seeking riches and gold that
would probably be pretty good at finding
a key I chose a defender of treasure
Smaug
this man this dragon it's not only so
intense that it would be a very
automatic defensive move but his offense
is insane and he can get around like one
of the biggest problems in ready player
1 is getting around because it cost
money and has all these this dude can
fly and he's that big plus it's an 80s
reference and that to me it was really
important because a lot of the heart of
ready player one was that it was a 1780s
it felt like a Stephen King like flavor
it had that stranger things in this and
that was really important because before
Peter Jackson decided to sleep and let
someone else direct The Hobbit films
this was a character that was important
to the 80s and we didn't have a negative
yet so I would love the idea of
redeeming Smaug and making it the nerd
glory that keeps saying smile makes us
all feel and this character would be the
best at all the tasks and that's vital
so not only is it a reference not only
is it 80s but it's actually a good
offensive and defensive move its mouth
alright charlie if we talk about class
system if we talk about who's like a
leader of the 80s when I think about all
these things put together as well as a
personal holy figure of mine I think of
Gareth the Goblin King from labyrinth
I think of Bowie himself leading the
people through his bulge first not only
would he be an oasis and people want him
to be any party you throw anywhere he
wants to go that would or would go wide
open but he's also king of labyrinth so
if you're looking for a key you want
someone who understands a puzzle who
understands labyrinths and that's what
jerath is all about also I to talk about
smiling being an 80s reference I the
cartoon is great but no one thinks as
long as Annie's reference they think of
labyrinth as an 80s movie and mine is
the only character that really is
thought of as an eighties character who
wouldn't want to see Gareth roll up in
his power metal hair band haircut and
make the party that much better all
right this is my favorite verses Zord
from The Fifth Element
smoke is tough it's tough to be smoked I
would imagine you Giants you can't go
indoors
you can't drive you don't need you can
fly if your voice is the same as I
assumed been to Cumberbatch right you
have this map voice yeah or the the
awesome voice in the animated series
it's really hard to carry on a
conversation you're essentially blind so
that's gonna be really hard to plant the
game you've got good senses but today
this is like yours is the best for
parties and yours is the best for
coolness I'm not trying to be a hard
year to be cool I'm trying to win the
competition of finding these things I'll
be unique you would find stuff in that
port over here that's how you play the
game how can you find something with
little dragon hands are like like
precision all the things you're gonna
know how to defeat snog your goblin bees
are things that are easily defeated the
bulge on the dragon argue has never been
defeated
he lets Sarah think that she won because
you see him at the end of moving he
flies away he got exactly does get
solved by a teenage behind like in like
behind the retro video arcade cabinet
the keys are like in very specific tough
to determine place someone do that for
you you I can it's about winning
she's also away sis where you want to be
amongst people you won't be amongst this
one because it seemed the Internet this
will happen to all of us but jerath is
just gonna be bombarded by weird sex
stuff for my brief like five minutes on
second life people are going to try to f
you no matter where you go and keys are
fighting or having fun and you're gonna
be like dense numbers and orgies like
that's a fashion icon but what is he
really gonna do he also lost he altered
quickly sir and the gun didn't do much
fun is actually utilized what did he
almost killed the fifth element the
supreme blade Chris Tucker helped take
him out
what does crew they never in a scene at
the same time but he was part of the
downfall of this character this is a
movie where like it was the downfall of
this is just who I would be this isn't
like we're not actually being the
characters making decisions
we're choosing some of his money won't
translate you said the class system
because you play a rich character
doesn't mean you're suddenly rich and if
that was the case I have all the gold in
middle-earth nobody likes and that movie
is today dragons your avatar so you do
not have the business acumen like smog
is the only one that can actually play
offensively but like amongst these two I
can play he wants to be back in his cave
over his goal wants to win he wants to
be along the entire point as long as he
wants Smaug is your avatar right the
character that wants to go forward and
succeed with all the powers right so
many dragon avatars I could be running
around ready player ones bunnies Jared
only one Goblin King right so you can be
crushed easily by all the dragons oh I
would rather be Gareth is so much worse
than David Bowie
coasting off of David Bowie's greatness
alter does it spawned orbs try to Jack
some rationality closing arguments we're
not closing but I want to hear from you
guys like why why you doing this carrot
as your avatar I don't hear about the
you know the characters in the movies is
like this is the carrot this is your
playable character why is yours the best
charlie I'll start with you why is why
is Jared the best playable character
he's the best playable character because
not only does he look fantastic and have
a bulge to die for his very viscid would
open up doors on both sides of ready
player ones like oasis you've got the
side of the the being around parties and
people and socializing and that aspect
and then you've got the gameplay part of
it because he is emblematic of puzzles
and labyrinths and if you can be the
puzzle maker or the game master you can
solve a game Ilan's the game master
accessibility is your car he's a master
of many worlds and many words many
openings down three times Spencer Joerg
accessibility is fine but I'd rather
have versatility I'd rather have a guy
who is charismatic but not so
charismatic that'll be diverted in a you
know bold stuff every 5 seconds I want a
guy who's well equipped he's got guns
he's got firepower he's got okay if he
has access to his company or not that's
that's a moot point I think that he
would he's a human being with regular
human sized hands that could do human
stuff that the game requires without
being as awkward and unwieldy as a giant
dragon
all right and Kois now I feel that the
only character that can get around
quickly the only character that has a
literal firepower cuz he's if dragon and
the only character that can intimidate
others into doing what he wants is smile
you have two human characters who
literally like one of them would be
constantly being attempted to be
molested and we wouldn't have the
accessibility because the the problem of
the enemies in that book and show are
going to be this this
I heard government a government's not
gonna want a sex god running around
they're gonna fight them as much as they
can and a government's also not gonna
want a tyrant of government and business
running around that clearly is insane
that movie he makes a lot of very
irrational choices they're gonna go
after an irrational businessman they're
gonna go after someone that is a problem
with their culture a dragons gonna be
hard to fight no matter how many feel
you come after him and I can get around
and kill people and convince you to do
whatever I need mine is the avatars to
the intelligence of me playing the game
with all the power of a dragon I can use
the Dragons merits and handle the
business
argument and I haven't read ready player
one so help me out here
is a lot of you were saying it's just
you're it's your skin it's your avatar
so it wouldn't actually be limiting like
you couldn't pick something up if you
were small to make that clear right
that's what I'm reading a lot of it's
like you could still do everything it
would just look stupid the number one
thing that people latch up to in this
read was quois pronunciation of a lot of
others a lot of people just wet didn't
really focus on the treasure-hunting
aspect just went with like badass tough
characters right a lot of like Batman
t1000 Mulan came up a lot
Wolverine Hellboy Hermione Granger the
bride those were the sort of answers we
were getting in the chin interesting I'm
this is a very difficult choice for me
and one wouldn't what were you thinking
I know you're a defender out like so are
you limited by what your character I do
in the Oasis is debatable yes you know I
I would have to say in terms of the
coolness factor like who I would want to
be representing me in this world it is
hard to top jerath the Goblin King and I
thought Charlie did a pretty good job
and I'm not this way to buy everybody in
the Oasis wants to have sex with you
like isn't that one gets the job done
Spencer I liked your your argument about
the the deep nerd reference that coming
well-equipped and coy brought along the
offensive capability and easily able to
fly and get around you all brought
different qualities to the table that's
what makes this a very difficult
decision you know I I was off this train
early in the fight but I think the
second half of the fight you won me over
I think coy with smile won me over
toward the end and then I was off the
smell train when I think with the use of
travel offensive capabilities I think
that those benefits outweigh the
negatives that they brought up and you
guys I don't think quite sold me on why
yours would be better so coy gets the
point thirty nine percent of YouTube
viewers went to mount one both folds ten
percent of my reason fitting smile goes
dear everything alright round for the
emoji movie opened last week guys and
Dunkirk barely beat it so evil doesn't
always win in this world sometimes
Dunkirk can beat the emoji movie the
emoji movie is in theater still
shockingly a lot of people thought this
is the worst a lot of critics said is
the worst movie in the world but I will
agree with that is maybe one of the
worst ideas in the world however because
this is movie fights and we say no to
any kind of barriers that like it's in
our way I would have you guys to pitch
at me and the audience at home a worse
movie idea than the emoji movie it's a
hefty tab
I'm being first oh boy it's just a worse
idea than the emoji believe this train
of destruction
so in this was tricky because the
phrasing is a worse movies I didn't know
to describe why it was like so I'm just
gonna describe a movie that shouldn't
exist and probably will because that is
the time we live in
yeah we live in an age of Millennials we
live in a time where everyone is judging
Millennials we live in a time where
millennial memes are as important we
live in a time where everyone's pointing
fingers and saying like this generation
is bad this generation bad and blaming
each other and my movie involves
defeating that gap ending generational
disparity and solving everything with
the power of fidget spinors now the
beauty of the fidget spinner is it
solves all of your fidgety needs and it
really helps you focus when you're a DD
and just a sad sad millennial and in my
movie aliens have overcome the planet
they've taken all of our energy sources
they've just taken over and there's
nothing we can do but the only energy
source we have left is as young MIT
Millennials have learned to summon the
power of the fidgets and every single
kid that has twitchy hands and doesn't
know what to do with all that built-up
frustration and lack of mortgages use
this all of their energy and the world
realizes hey Millennials aren't so bad
they saved us with fidget spenders okay
it might seem a little sum in the power
of terrible idea
charlie is do you have a worse one do I
feel like I do so with the emoji movie
it went for big blockbuster popcorn fare
for the whole family yes I'm going for
something that's going to annoy
everybody because it's going to be the
peak up your butt like arthouse film
sorry the peak up your butt so I thought
wouldn't it be great if we had this dog
195 lars von trier type arthouse movie
where all it is so all the ad campaigns
are gifts so we see just other movies
taking from everyone else's movie and
that's every poster every ad campaign is
just one second of movement
that's it but the actual film itself are
two men in a stark room at a table
arguing whether it is pronounced gif or
Jif that's the whole movie that is an
hour and a half of someone arguing over
to gif versus jiff
whether it's g4 graphic or gif or peanut
butter that is the whole there's no real
plot it's just an argument between
people that would be horrendous that's
worse than anything that anyone who has
ever put in the landmark theater that's
la is a gift / Jeff movie but the movie
itself is about an argument tear
household's apart and also do about the
pronunciation it's it's a gift in a room
fighting over the pronunciation all
right the Internet incarnate that does
sound like a terrible idea
Spencer do you have a worse idea than
the above I hope so
I'm gonna pitch you guys a movie based
on the Lacroix mildly flavored sparkling
waters they are sparkling cans of
sparkling water
they have big bright colors on them but
they barely taste like anything and
they're getting really popular right now
so I want to make a movie that was kind
of true to the theme and stuff of
Lacroix which is to be different but
like very mildly different so that
barely anyone notices so it's like a
teen ensemble kind of like a Power
Rangers origin story of all these teens
going through like really subtle
[ __ ] problems like you know the guy
who plays berry the berry flavor is like
suspended but like just for one football
game and you know lemon like left I mean
comment on Facebook on someone's picture
and lime is like 1/8 latina and it's
struggling there the cans no they okay
they're teens the teens but they are
about they're selected by the water
force the water for such as a talking
river imbues them with the power of La
Croix which is the power to make
sparkling water taste like vaguely
subtly flavored sparkling water this is
the magic power that they're given and
their town has a big Perrier Factory who
does unflavored sparkling water okay
there's a you know there's a struggle
between their parents who work at the
factory and them and the Perrier is
trying to get rid of them but they end
up adding Mild flavors to the sparkling
water of the town okay I don't have
titles from any of you so Chloe what is
the title of your millennial fidget
spinner
oh um fidget bones to the point there's
a period on the poster though fidget
with it with the period oh so it's like
a command yeah okay it's a call okay
okay Charlie what the it's not even gif
or Jif it's just the yes Queen mouthing
yeah that's Queen it's just the gift
it's the yes Queen yes gif slash Jenna
thing okay Spencer what's the name of
your movie
mine is wet mild wet and ' mild what mmm
mild alright interesting guys why are
your ideas worse than his flavoring
water visual that's not a visual concept
it's not an interesting concept the
teens aren't even dealing with real
problems to see your lars von trier art
film about what you say it's about [ __ ]
versus gift but that can be about so
much more under the surface that's like
my dinner with Andre is just about two
guys having dinner it'll turn on life
it's about philosophy interpreters used
to live your life whereas gif and jiff
can reveal like do you are like you into
the original meaning of God or like the
new one like it can be this whole battle
of philosophies between these two guys
in this room lars von trier I checked
that out people would look he didn't
actually direct it's just a sand dog 95
guys yes this is why I feel but love
yours is because people have a really
passionate passionate favorite in
lacroix households they love their
coconut they love their pumpkin mousse
they have people they want a bad news oh
yeah it's already selling it's already
selling you foreigners are selling to
doesn't mean it's a good move
mine's insulting to both adults and
children literally alienates everyone
it's embarrassing children people love
it you couldn't even stop doing it it
was fun you do it I was entertained the
fidgets spinners are fun but the movie
would literally be like the worst part
of scooby-doo - it would be alienating
everyone that loves the actual thing
this was a spinner movie that was like
an anime and they were fighting with
fidget spinners and that was awesome I
found the kids are the kind that's fun
it's like amusing premise for a movie
but times if I agree them is ironic -
house it's it's Dallas Pierce video
carnage it would do well in these places
like it so that came it isn't actually
yeah it's like Empire State it's like an
interesting theoretical film to check
out of two people arguing over the same
time I'm curious they don't even come up
with an answer at the end of it you're
just left there's no answer have you
seen with Jake Gyllenhaal it's a movie
about Jake Gyllenhaal and a twin that's
an actor and the whole movie he's trying
to find this twin and then he finds him
and then it goes and then it goes to
credits yeah your boy does already made
that movie Locker he's just in a car
talking to himself yeah but I'm saying
that people will see this interesting
will not connecticut's of Indian art
houses and people won't show up for it
thank you all for both ease like I like
looking at Jerry gifts yeah and you will
me a campaign you says it's all gonna be
one second the actual movie itself is
bad because it has nothing sorry man why
yours is the most terrible idea out of
these three terrible ideas not where the
people will see it why is it the worst
thing but I can argue why mine's bad by
arguing that there's our good because
the fidgets spinners they're like a
worldwide phenomenon it's about the
movie being not about the face under
worst idea ever
gathering people - it's doing all of the
worst parts about teen movies it's
trying to be overbearing and that we
need to unite it's trying to be
overbearing and that kids on a dole team
units trying to be overbearing and that
like we're the next thing it's literally
insulting everyone watching is the first
birth plot there yeah but
just because it's a plot doesn't mean
it's good there's a movie featuring
Tremblay that came out that doesn't as a
plot but it's not good like just said
the plot doesn't make it good this movie
is not fitting out of the audience it's
not fair to the people viewing it and
it's insulting to the product because it
makes the product seem like more than it
is the reason fitted sweaters are it's
because they're so linear I'm trying to
make everything better than it is with
this crappy movie and wait you're
talking about a better product that
people are already annoyed with I know
like hipsters like it but people in
general like this is stupid it's
overpriced flavored water and they're
coming in with a favorite they're coming
in with like it's like Pokemon for water
you can come any of your team you're
driving with an open boat at emu that
intentionally undercuts drama itself
very mild undramatic movie their powers
are to make water flavored like slightly
more flavored water it's boiling world
it's the Wonder Years but with a brand
marketing he wants you have someone
going through a lot of Sun do you have
puberty you've a lot of things are going
to happen that emboldened tears if you
made them cans of soda that would be a
bad movie beat made them teenagers and
teenagers inherently have interesting
events are inherently annoying they are
not interested they're not bad this
doesn't make a bad movie I'll knock down
your move each other's movies a lot I
gave you all to sell me one last time
why is your idea the worst idea out of
these three ideas Spencer I'm gonna
start with you bad plot mm-hmm low
stakes characters who are intentionally
mild it's visually uninteresting because
you're looking at water the whole time
the water doesn't even change color it's
just the flavor and it's just got a bad
message it's it's got a bad message of
like you know it doesn't matter what's
on the inside it's what's on the it
mildly different about you on the
outside that counts just taste it just
taste it doesn't have the real thing
all right Coyne why is your idea the
worst out of these ideas you guys
described why the item is bad my movie
is bad which never got touched upon my
movie is Michael Bay meets Roland
Emmerich meets and disgusting people
there's no no it's all the worst things
about Armageddon plus the most annoying
characters it's every character you hate
in the movie put in one movie it's that
like sidekick character you can't stand
as the main character times a team of
them it's every stereotype for adults
and for kids and it's unwatchable
because the dialogue makes you hate both
sides of the people the action isn't
interesting the biggest action set piece
is this the reason this is fun in real
life is it gives you something to do
when you watch this in a movie you're
not gonna get the release of the fidget
you're just gonna experience someone
else getting the fidget I mean that's
redeeming there's nothing that allows it
to grow I'd be interested in the PSA
aspect I'd be interested in the art
house aspect mine is the worst common
denominator of films it's a summer
blockbuster without the blockbuster
alright and Charlie why is yours the
worst idea people love these films these
are so bad they're good films they show
up they have a good time they take
semester curriculars they have a nice
afternoon my movie it's a test of
endurance to get through we're talking
three hours of two men who are not
actors sitting across from each other
arguing about the pronunciation they're
not deviating from the subject matter
they're not talking about interesting
things they're literally talking about
the pronunciation of this word it is
bleak it is distressing it is not fun
for everybody and everyone comes home
sad terrible movie alright one any of
fact-checking
in this in this [ __ ] what's the overall
tone of the internet right now wow there
were there was a lot of disagreement
about which of these movies sounded good
a lot of people were saying there were
one of these movies like I would watch a
fidget spinner movie or like that
Lacroix pitch sounds kind of good to me
some of the some of these suggestions
that came up Botanica s-- Sharman bears
wiping their butts the movie came up
yeah a lot of people are saying a Back
to the Future remake would be the worst
possible pitch Tetris came up a bunch
Pixar's toilets and then Nicolas Cage
reading mind Kampf a lot of surprised
that nobody picked that dancing hot dog
from snapchat where's the dancing kids
already out there it's a difficult one
for me because I feel like there were
worse ideas and live you guys got kind
of caught in the nitty-gritty of what
you were you know I feel like we could
have gotten worse given what we have I
Charlie yours and I think they kind of
said it's like maybe people wouldn't go
see it but it holds a weird kind of
fascination in a weird way the dog 195
things tells me more the worst idea
because it kind of intrigues me so it's
between coy and Spencer and a coy you
certainly were the most vocal about
selling it but I kind of got lost with
the whole Michael Bay meets Roland
Emmerich
I'm not it didn't your description of
the movie itself didn't really sell to
me why it was that bad and the others in
the plot which is the Millennials and
the power of fidget spinners even the
name I could kind of see that happening
so Spencer you're closing our meet we're
strong he's bad plot low-stakes visually
uninteresting bad message they're
literally turning water into less
flavorful water it was the combination
of poor idea and poor execution looking
for in this round suspension
point Spencer he gets the point in now
my face is still screwed up from the
once if I take just awful
alright round five Spencer probably not
spoken Charlie you could get a spot
where Spencer can run up the score I'm
gonna have to go to a tiebreaker between
you two depends on this question wet hot
American summer ten years later comes
out I think at midnight tonight on
Netflix and a set is set ten minutes ten
minutes ten years after the red hot
American summer of course did is one
that was ten years or the day before but
we wanted to ask what movie would you
like to see a 10 years later TV series
about so this is it could be Netflix it
can be HBO it could be whatever you like
but it's set ten years later what movie
do you think would have the best
adaptation to that format and Charlie
I'm gonna start with you so I I think
like a lot of people here have a problem
with sequels a lot of time they've got
to earn being a sequel they've got to
earn being a TV show what do I want to
see from these characters that I haven't
seen yet what can we learn about them
and who they are at this point in their
lives so 10 years is a big leap in time
and I want someone young someone who had
a lot of feelings and a specific time
their life and now 10 years later who
are who are they now what are they
feeling and when you hear feelings you
hear inside out I want to know what that
girl's going through at 21 she went from
11 to 21 and that's a whole new ball
game she's exiting college she's
entering the workforce what does that
mean was I mean for romance what does
that mean for dealing with her parents
and who they are now are they retiring
at this point are they coming into a new
phase of their lives themselves they can
meet at that point I just feel like 21
is that kind of age where you're still
pretty young and you're soft in a lot of
ways but you're about to enter a big
world and I would love to see that over
a series and see what that arc looks
like on television alright inside out 21
years old Spencer what was your choice
I'm gonna go with The Big Lebowski and I
think that people kind of confuse what
makes a great movie and what makes a
great TV show I think with film you want
to see character growth and you want to
see change
TV you just want to hang out with your
favorite characters week to week you
want Pete you're literally inviting
people into your home to have a good
time and who doesn't want to spend more
time with the dude with Walter with the
Jesus with nihilus and and Donnie's
ghost who only Walter sees I'm bringing
back the Big Lebowski mr. Jimmy come
back as the ghost yes because the ghost
that only Walter can see gotcha yeah
alright The Big Lebowski ten years later
and COI I am fighting for something near
and dear to my heart I'm fighting for a
franchise that needs to be saved I'm
fighting for something that should be on
TV instead of a movie I am fighting of
course for the x-men in the beginning
the x-men was the first franchise that
really kicked things off along with
spider-man but x-men is extremely
important for where superheroes are now
but if you go back and watch the x-men
it is a mutant movie it's not an x-men
movie the beautiful thing about TV is it
gives you time to invest in multiple
characters it gives you time to care
about different character arcs it gives
you time to really see what each person
is going through and to be a part of
their life x-men is a team two hours is
not enough to invest in a team two hours
is not enough to introduce so if you
turner and already have a Phoenix thing
two hours is not enough to have found
condense and go Phoenix and then
disappear to water and then come back at
the third row director that franchise
has been abused and it had to because it
got us to where we are in this glorious
age of superhero movies but if we had a
TV series that was an actual x-men TV
series not the gifted which features
such d-list x-men as blink and people
that don't matter to the people that
want to see this we can actually have a
continuation of the x-men and it belongs
on a TV medium and it's where it should
have started but we weren't there yet so
not only is it important for the
franchise it's important for the state
of superheros like so we don't have the
bubble burst that's inevitable if we
don't move things in the right direction
so x-men x-men inside out and Big
Lebowski guys so I believe in your
passion that there should be an x-men
but I don't know which x-men which x-men
or ten years later jump which has worked
out so well for the x-men movies well
you have professors and then you
interview students that actually matter
you introduce you can have an almost
Generation X flavor by having the
perfect you already care about the
professor's because we've met them we've
lived in them we know them so you
already have a beautiful Harry Potter s
world where the professor's are
interesting and now the new students are
interesting and you get to meet
like half the cast of the original x-men
maybe like yeah Hugh Jackman if you can
get him to do a weekly TV show good luck
but if you bring back like Halle Berry's
storm this working picture you're not
gonna get Julianne Moore Jeff Bridges
John Goodman Jeff Bridges is open to it
the entirety of your cast and also ten
years later where why the same you want
to know you want you know that they're
not going to change exactly that's not
saying the difference between TV and
film is that you don't want these
characters that you love to be different
from the characters that you love you
want to hang out with these people that
you've already gotten to know and see
how they react to a different challenge
one two week Jerry Seinfeld's Jerry
Seinfeld every week I wouldn't never
Bart Simpson every week the dude is
gonna be the dude every week and he's
gonna get in some confusion even if it's
just like going to an Apple store or
going bowling like it doesn't need to be
a big high concept show it's just the
misadventures of this group of friends
that you love hanging out but the
beautiful thing about the Big Lebowski
is it's Buddhist it's Zen its lean its
crisp it has a beautiful arc where
you're invested in the beautiful
simplicity of the dude if you try to
stretch that out beyond two hours you're
going to lose the simplicity and lose
the beauty of the bums me out is it's
not you have this perfect film you don't
bring it to TV it's gonna lose that much
if you were talking and talk about
ruining something you are gonna take
inside out and drag it to the weirdest
possible players you have 21 years old
that's what the kids would have I know
it don't watch Pixar movies but then 10
years from now is a big jump for kids or
something inside out to then go to like
I'm a 21 year old I'm going to the club
I'm getting hammered and I'm like heaven
I don't need to see what a boyfriend
what is the there watching Netflix of
all ranges that's not an argument
against it you're still using that 10
years to its best capabilities what does
that 10 years mean that's 10 years from
a character we met at 11 and now she's
21 that's a that's a jump that you'd
want to see play out and how that would
be on an episodic you cannot do that 22
minutes at a time I can't fathom
investing these character that's of
course soap the animation to be cheaper
because if it's on TV
Pixar would be able to keep up the
workload Pixar makes the movie every
five years so it doesn't
looks crappy just from a story
standpoint and I would not want to watch
a crappy looking x-men TV x-men is with
Fox oh it's already got a bunch of Tartu
got a house they should be able to have
the money it's gonna look horrible as
agents of ceiling still looks like crap
compared the more you have in the
mansion is where Andy said it'd be a
school show so the no no you get to care
about the character ninety show and it
didn't do very well but the 90s x-men
showed it extremely well
[Music]
live-action miniseries that they tried
to make into your show because they
don't have the top of the budget then
because they do a budget now look at
Inhumans that looks terrible all your
getting spoiled we get an x-men movie
every single year they're not good with
American was amazing those are Fox
tension we don't last in the Carol
Logan's on x-men movie really I don't
think our Wolverine time to invest the
reason Logan was good we'll use that
example is because you have the time to
invest into characters with the show you
can invest in two characters at a time
you have the time to stretch it out with
inside out the budget wouldn't allow for
animation to look anything guns not sure
if you've seen any Netflix show going on
trips like troll hunter the animation is
let's imagine bonus under the sureties
show but with something like x-men we're
burnt out from x-men what does is 10
years do for it gives like that each of
those students as professors it gives us
min show shows don't make any sort of
you don't like that x-men is every
character makes you feel welcomed the
x-men the point of x-men is so you can
understand what an outsider feels like
that's how does the ten years later
plays - everyone's the 10 years is
important because now Iceman isn't their
little crazy rebel he's a professor now
Kitty Pryde isn't someone she's leading
the she's the headmistress
you get to imagine like you've wanted to
the characters that you love from the
movie becoming adults and leading new
children that's why x-men works is
because as it evolves
teachers become professors professors
them teach new students so then do they
ever leave to school or is it just math
the ones that one and that way you'll
have to worry about scheduling stuff
that's why you can you can have which
actors you want the thing with it the
inside out it doesn't work for 10 years
is because the 21 year olds a bunch of
bell engineers
they do have a professor rogue don't
they don't see your TV show gives me
that's new from the movie and I want
something new and the x-men can't give
me that one Herman's head Charlie to
admit it and I didn't get to enjoy
Herman's head young so now we get a
really interesting take on this concept
but didn't get to go long enough and
really explore I think it was the
perfect amount it was about someone
growing up and she grew up but that's
that's insane out the movie but but we
now see her at ten years and what that
woman is now and what her relationship
is like with our parents what their life
is like some gloomy to me that sounds
like a sequel movie lapto story to these
shows right now is they have that sort
of scope where you get into all these
deep dives of the characters and find
out where they are and it doesn't delete
right Briley to put her back together
cuz she's very well adjusted at the end
of it inside out she knows that like joy
and sadness away together as humans ever
like broken and not put back together we
memories are dying to explore the world
as you know it and try to deal with all
the emotions going in every weeks ago
like oh I'd like to know I wouldn't
invest enough to know what she's up to
no I haven't rewatch them sent out more
than twice I wouldn't watch every single
week but the movie versus a TV show I
don't feel like you're lucky enough to
get were the little emotions enough to
invest when I want to reach you guys is
the tone of your show and how is it
taking advantage of this episodic TV
format Spencer if you haven't heard a
lot about more about people about sure I
think that the tone of it is more
comedic like then then Fargo the TV show
which is another Coen Brothers
adaptation where they're like oh that'll
never work and it turns out it's
incredible where you are taking the
characters and the tone are the same as
the movie but yeah the plot week-to-week
is something different and I think apart
from you guys who are arguing like oh we
need to add more story and take the plot
in different directions I think what you
want to do is preserve the characters
and not have them change you're just
putting them in a different world ten
years later to see how they would react
to the modern day or ten years after Big
Lebowski
to see how they how they would handle
challenges in a decade later all right
Charlie inside-out how
the tone of the show and how would it
take advantage of being a TV show
episodically I just want to say that
Fargo works because it's an anthology
series and you've got a lot you and you
also have Noah Holly so that's the
virtue of Fargo you may also - Holly I
said so
so with inside-out what I love about
what's going on I'm specifically Netflix
right now is you get these deep dives
into characters in a very serial comic
way and inside out is literally serial
comic you've got joy and sadness coming
together and the human experience is
taking all these nuances and emotion and
putting them together and bringing it to
the rest of your life it's such a
beautiful concept and such a thing that
you can share with the people around you
the family could sit down and watch this
show and deal with the different things
coming into her life but the families
dealing with ten years later this is the
only show of the three that deals with
the ten-year concept what it means to
these characters now who they are what
the world is like and who they can be
going forward it uses every part of the
lessons they learn in the interim and
then looks towards the future you were
there with her you care about her and
you learn and you love any laughs and
it's a beautiful serial comic show okay
so you know serious so each episode
would be would it be like a different
issue or it would be her going through
her life dealing with the different
things that come up - looking for a job
dealing with a parent maybe gets sick or
she has a fight with one of them or she
has a fight with her boyfriend that's
never explored because she's 11 years
old so obviously you wouldn't deal with
that in that sort of movie right the
natural progression of what ten years
would bring you in a life of a person
all right and then coy tone of the show
and how does it take advantage of the
episodic the tone of the show is very
much like what the x-men comics feel
like it is learning why it's okay to be
different it is learning what it's like
to be an outsider and accepting it each
week you can have a new problem and you
can have overarching stories throughout
the the reason it's a TV show is the
reason daredevil works is because it has
an arc you can invest in multiple
characters a team shouldn't be a movie
at the go that's why Avengers led up to
it this allows for us to invest in each
character it needs to be that kind of
show it's a drama it is I love I love
the idea of say my bell vexman but it's
a drama instead of a comedy I want to
invest in these kids they're high
schoolers for reason and the reason 10
years makes sense is like you said x-men
3 had a student become a teacher it's a
continuation of something 10 years later
we can see how these characters that we
care about evolve and we can meet new
students so it has a beautiful it's
built in to have scheduling issues
resolved it's built in to have
characters characters that we want to
see where they land and I want to know
where the x-men landed and I want to
know why new characters are important
and I but x-men 3 wasn't good this
allows us to redeem these things and we
need a show where people feel like they
not only are accepted and we can have
all the emotional stakes of that and we
can have all the relaxing care to be
loved of that but in a show that takes
place in a Canada universe that feels
like the x-men comics alright one any
fact checks and what's the what is the
tone of the world like it's not a fact
check but a lot of people in the YouTube
comments were upset that none of the
fighters brought up Legion as a
counter-argument
I just want to there is already a sort
of like after x-men show I'm just thanks
to the messenger guy Jeff Bridges did
tell variety that he would be open to a
big lebowski sequel however the Coen
brothers have said they are not at all
interested in following up interestingly
John Turturro is making a film right now
it's in post-production called going
places where he is bringing back Jesus
Krypton so he is playing his character
again but that's that's all we're
getting for that and then a lot of
people said Star Wars which I thought
was weird because we don't know how did
you do 10 years after we don't know
what's coming yeah that's surely another
big spoilers for the movie other big
suggestions Harry Potter Breakfast Club
came up a lot serenity a contention the
number one most requested the
professional people were saying they
want to see Mattel yeah all grown up now
is a assassin herself as I said Nikita
basically Portman Envy from in dead oh
yeah exactly
this is as Dakota Andy this is very
tough because III none of you really
sold me fully on your concept Spencer I
see what you're saying as far as you
preserve the characters and is you just
hanging out week to week Seinfeld The
Simpsons are the same I get that with
the the comedic things I'm having
trouble chai I get where you're saying
charlie it gets it's dealing with the
issues and its new things that would
work though I'm just trying to think how
it would work and they also brought up
the suit the idea of like that sounds
like a good idea for a sequel movie but
is it a good idea for a TV show and then
x-men we've seen it we say yeah it's
we've seen it but I'm trying to say I
think I'm gonna yeah I think that the
movie the movie argument kind of knocked
it inside out for me as far as like this
is like a good idea for a sequel movie
but that concept I don't know I just
don't see it working as a weekly show
which takes it down to Big Lebowski and
x-men for me and it's really the choice
between dudes that do preserve the
comedic characters we know and put them
in different situations every week which
is kind of the sitcom strategy or
advance the storyline and give different
sides to it I don't know I don't love
either ones but based on those arguments
I'm gonna have to give the edge to COI
and with x-men like so cool you get the
point that's a very difficult decision
boy gets the point of that wine I'm sure
they're yelling are they in there laughs
they never leave the school really both
poles are really close yeah we have a
tie on Twitter right now mm-hmm
35% for both inside out and big lebowski
they disagree with you but x-men right
behind with 30 so it's really close all
around and then YouTube's slight edge
Big Lebowski with 35% inside-out 30 for
x-men 30 Wow so it's very tight very
technology that could have gone any
number of ways and I just had to pick
one that's part of being the judge why
it's not fun sometimes you just have to
pick one all right Charlie I'm sorry to
say you will not be moving under the
speed round but you're gonna help me
judge these answers why now also as Andy
likes to say activate you to help me not
quantity now go ahead and speed around a
chance to win five more points I will
ask you you know how this all right how
much high is it 15 or 20 20 and 10 10 10
second republic I will ask you five
additional questions or however many we
need to to the terminal winner you each
have 20 seconds to answer and then the
10 second rebuttal if both of you say
the same answer at the no I mean I can
make this mistake that is usually men on
the show if both if one of you says an
answer first you get that answer the
other will have to go for a backup
answer if you both say the same answer
at the same time I don't know what we do
the same answer whoever says it first
gets that answer then you'll have to do
a backup answer any questions right
let's do it all right ready question one
antman and the wasp is starting
production what is the best non Marvel
movie featuring Paul Rudd
yeah got a couple yeah I've got 200 that
you're playing chess interesting speed
repeat chest it's
I'll say I Love You Man Spencer goes
with I Love You Man
knocked up boy has chosen knocked up I
Love You Man vs. knocked up Spencer you
answered first so you will be the first
to answer lond we have 20 seconds on the
clock all right Spencer I Love You Man
I Love You Man I Love You Man is an
original movie in the in the skin of a
rom-com but it's between two men and
it's about a topic that's just never
explored so much which is just male
friendship without although are they gay
are they not gay
it's it's a subject of a movie that
really hasn't been taken on in a broad
comedic way before and they just nail it
Paul Rudd is so likable Jason Segel is
so funny coy knocked up knocked up
similarly handles the subject matter
that's usually reserved for a different
type of movie this is a movie through a
bro comedy dick joke movie about
pregnancy it makes men understand
pregnancy more it makes men understand
women more it makes men actually see
what it's like to be on that side of it
it's a man movie about pregnancy and
it's beautifully done because you're
invested in all the characters the
comedies real the last surreal and it
started this whole wave of comedy we
have today about the dick joke type
thing not stuff allowed there are other
better movies for me that helped me
understand women there's so many that
have been made for precious that's a bad
example but I Love You Man is unique
it's one of one wow it's not just what
understanding women it's about
understanding how men relate to women
and making them actually characters
fully fleshed out making the jokes
heartfelt making the comedy real and
making you understand all the people in
movie all the supporting characters
mattered much of the leaves and everyone
matters everyone's heartfelt okay
shockingly no one really mentioned Paul
Rudd at all
I'm gonna go to you first what are you
thinking I thought both fighters came
out really strong but I thought koi
definitely and the rebuttal came back
much harder and I convinced me Charlie
what are your thoughts so it was tough
because I was expecting to hear more how
Paul Rudd featured in Sarah knocked up
was a strange choice for me from the
sound of it but you did you didn't pull
it out for me I thought that sounded
that sound like a better movie to me
from your arguments
yeah bond I'm with you I was I was kind
of late for Spencer but I thought that
Spencer bungled the rebuttal a little
bit it came out a little stronger for me
on knocked up in the rebuttal so I'm
gonna give that point to coy so coy you
pull ahead three to two versus precious
reference question to the Dark Tower as
we mentioned before or I don't know if
we did we didn't we were going to
mention it but we did not is hitting
theaters it's a very simple question
interest elbow or Matthew McConaughey
McConaughey yourself all right Spencer I
heard you say McConaughey first
McConaughey is done at all this is a guy
that started as a cheesy rom-com lead
and then he became just like an everyday
working actor and then he rose like a
phoenix into the Makana saans you love
you he's made you like think in true
detective he's made you cry in Dallas
buyers club he's made - do you know what
in Magic Mike he's a guy that has
actually amazing range but he's also
kind of a you Makana actually started
really strong and is infused and he
needed a Meccano silence because of all
the bad choices he made there was a
series of movies that were just awful he
just fell that hasn't gone down that
path he's in beasts of no nation he's
incredible in it he's in movies there he
makes the material better this guy wants
to be bond this guy his bond leaves
haven't let him eat yet McConaughey
can't do that he made him a con sense he
needed to recover
undersell that hasn't had a messed up
because he's consistently the best piece
of all material he does there's a reason
people went hide yourself for everything
McConaughey doesn't have it all right a
second okay it's just slow parse what
you said there all right it's Spencer
rebuttal
he just helped I hasn't had the low lows
that Makani has or the high highs
because he plays kind of the same thing
every time he's always the stoic cool
badass and yeah that's fine to be in
every movie but I don't see him
elevating his performance the same way
McConaughey's and showing the same
vulnerability he has boy disagree if you
look at rock and roll and you look at
visa Venetian you look at Mandela you
could look at there's an oscar-worthy
performance that's very different from
the last Oscar at the phones and rock
and roll is a fun guy rich to me this
guy he knew everything he has comedy he
has drama he's not in taking this
misstep so you're right he's not as low
Charlie I'm gonna ask you first god I'm
a sucker for Makana songs just the
mention of it makes me happy I think I
think brought it out at the end with
really listing the movies the Idris has
been in and shown range so I go I go
chorus that was a good counter punch
against arrange an argument lon
it was but I you know I don't feel he
did list a lot of movies that he'd
yourself was great in but I'm not sure
that I'm really convinced like like
Spencer did McConaughey has been in a
lot more kinds of genres and he's done a
lot more different performances I don't
I don't know that coy had a good answer
for that even though it was a good
rebuttal so I probably got Spencer yeah
Koizumi arraigned are you it was kind of
that inter stumble didn't need the
Makana saw it's I think that's kinda
what you hung your hat on but I didn't
sell me on the negatives of McConaughey
as much as Spencer told me and he made
you laugh you made you cry he sold me on
the range is different than the breadth
the length of the scope of his career he
is a good fight but I think we have to
go with Spencer and McConaughey on this
one tied up again three three three
questions left no this is a good one
okay alright okay I like this one
we recently reported that Suicide Squad
2 has lost its director who should step
into direct Suicide Squad to
steven soderbergh okay so yeah we can
pick anyone's not who actually would
take no no this is who should sit yeah
Tarantino couldn't turn alright Wow 90s
indie darling the Steven Soderbergh
versus Quentin Tarantino it's coy I
heard you say Soderbergh first so you
are first on the clock so Berger knows
how to shape a team oceans movies are
all about team they're all about making
individual characters important he knows
which characters do what he assembles a
puzzle and he makes everyone matter The
Suicide Squad needs to have each
individual puzzle matter it needs to go
forward and these have an arc all three
of those movies have arc whether or not
they're good each one has comedy each
one is the chops to lead this and as
directing sounds perfect comic Mia's
bright it's funny the editing is fast
everything about the way he directs is
suited for a comic movie plus the fact
that no Suicide Squad
I want talk about Tarantino is a fit for
Suicide Squad in particular Suicide
Squad is a group of gangsters that's all
Tarantino makes and Reservoir Dogs and
Pulp Fiction in the hateful eight these
are all bad people brought together to
do something around a common goal and
yes Suicide Squad has all these one at
least had all these weird pop-culture
flourishes and like editing and
references to other movies quick cuts a
lot of action it wasn't about a grounded
character movie mm all right
Tarantino doesn't make movies makes
Tarantino movies the studio and never
let him make a Tarantino movie David
Ayer try to make a movie that was David
Ayer and that's the Suicide Squad happen
Tarantino would just make another piss
box it would be a mess of movie and it
couldn't have him cuz here Encino
wouldn't have the rains do what he needs
to and suicides Kevin work soda burger
bean would bring a groundedness and a
realism that doesn't belong in this
franchise he turned Magic Mike that male
stripper movie into like a weird
character study I want to Suicide Squad
my movie that's bloody that's
action-packed it's frenetic mm1 what are
your thoughts you know like I think
Spencer had a really strong argument
that koi didn't responded which is the
gangster crime element is so in the
pocket of what sort of cutie doesn't and
I think it's
Squad movie that was a lot more like a
Tarantino movie would probably work
pretty well so yeah I think I got a go
Spencer Spencer Charlie what are you
thinking honestly the argument doesn't
work for me of like who would take the
job because this is fantasy yeah so
based on the arguments of what they
would bring to movie I side more with
Spencer because I want to see a gangster
bloody frenetic movie and that's what
tarantia would obviously bring to
suicide both side with Spencer Chloe had
a really good point though about it not
being about of being a Tarantino movie
and not a Suicide Squad movie hmm
see if I overrule you people are just
gonna say that I'm being vindictive
against Spencer but I think I think that
I've judged this pretty fairly so far I
you know I gotta go with my gut and the
style the team aspect the puzzle aspect
and the argument that they wouldn't
allow it to be a Suicide Squad movie to
be a Tarantino movie man I think we had
to go with coy on this one I'm gonna
have to I think I'm gonna have to pull
the overrule and ghost coy so that's
only of what there's still two questions
left no you're ahead by one okay so this
is a must-win for Spencer
it's my wrap this is a must for Spencer
what No okay here we go Detroit is
hitting theaters this week what's the
best movie directed by Kathryn Bigelow
its Hurt Locker Hurt Locker zero dark
thirty Spencer says zero dark thirty I
wanted to say Point Break but I both
first instinct on Point Break I'm gonna
fight just Point Break off it's not no
but I mean it's great but it's alright
Hurt Locker versus zero dark thirty coy
I believe you answered first so your
first on the clock Hurt Locker made you
feel like what is to be like at war in a
modern-day war setting that was the
first movie that really made us
understand how awful the modern warfare
felt like you invested in German
rhetoric started his career investment
anthony mackie started his career this
movie was so good you actually felt
you're in the trenches in the heat of
battle consistently for two hours the
moment were you standing there looking
at the aisle of cereal you felt like you
went to war with him and don't know how
to react in modern life I've never known
Spencer her locker sent you to war so
did zero dark thirty and it sent you
everywhere around the war this pulled
back to give you the scope of the entire
situation of the investigation of the
interrogation of the politics around it
and of the war that raid sequence in
ceará dark thirty is when the best
action filmmaking things ever put the
screen and it's a true story I know her
lock is based on real events but this
was a very actual event that could have
been so politicized are taken out of
context or screwed up and she nailed it
all right boy you didn't really care
about any individual soldier in that
movie it was so distracting because of
all the directions it took it didn't
feel like you were there didn't flake
her invested it told a very
documentary-style story very duck
immediately away I want to know my
characters are I want to be invested I
wanna be with them I disagree I cared
about Jessica test day in that whole
time the way she was shown in the way
she overcame adversity to actually
relentlessly track down her man over an
entire lifetime and yeah The Hurt Locker
yes that's a good shell-shocked soldier
story I've seen that character m1 what
are your thoughts this one was really
close
both made really great points and they
both really like did a good job
describing the differences between the
movie and how it worked for that movie I
will say I thought coy right at the end
sort of sold me a little bit more on the
you know the zero dark thirty so it's
sort of all over the place and Hurt
Locker is much more intimate gives you
more of a feel for the character so I
think I'd go with coy mmm Charlie I came
in with the bias cuz I like Hurt Locker
more than zero dark thirty but I really
like how Spencer brought up how Bigelow
took the the property and made it great
and and put it around her which I felt
was more towards the question and that
that sold it for me yeah it's it's very
close for me to the point that Spencer
made that I did not consider or that I
thought was kind of set it apart from
Hart lawmakers are both great war
stories they both make you feel further
protagonist I think you both brought
that up the one that Spencer said list
it's a real life event it could been
politicized it wasn't the action
filmmaking sequence it's in zero dark
thirty he just made that choice stand
out to me a little bit more so I'm
actually gonna go with Spencer on this
one which ties it up which means we're
going to one last question which one
would be the funny one or do I go with
yeah we're just having a good time the
wave of Catwoman here we go it's not fun
with this one right okay what movie
monster that would make the best pet
Clemmons
[Music]
is the Iron Giant a monster Joss
so grandma not quite what you say
gremlins you mean the gremlins
themselves are you talking about mom why
Ingram okay so the whole package well
yeah that's unfair okay
no sure no I just making sure all right
so gremlins versus Jaws where two movie
monster would make the best pet oh I
can't wait to hear this
boy you're up first mine are both cute
and cunning mine can both be used as
attack dogs and to snuggle with mine are
both very interesting and both aspects
and there's nothing cuter than a Mogwai
this is a creature that lives to be
adorable it's a phobia in real life but
better it is what inspired so much the
cuteness of the eighties it is a
creature made for love and then the
gremlins are intelligent they're fun
they're charismatic they're interesting
they're entertaining all right Spencer
car loads aren't charismatic they're
monsters don't ruin your entire life no
nothing's worse than having a
high-maintenance pet it's why there's so
many abandoned pot-bellied pigs people
think that they're gonna be Cupid it
turns out that there's too much carrot
so many roles you can't feed them at
this time yeah I can't put water and
jaws isn't just a sweet-ass sharp you
having a cool aquarium you just throw a
bunch of meat in it once in a while and
it's awesome thing to show off and it's
an awesome thing to look at it's gonna
make you the coolest guy in town you're
strapping a 10-foot 20-foot shark in a
tank what's more high maintenance in a
shark they're so hard to take care of it
you never get to pet them there's no
love there's no charisma there's no
interaction you're looking at a tank you
can just touch it playing on TV watch
jaws and get the same pet there's
nothing to that there's always gonna do
it you're gonna pentagram limbs gonna
bite your little hand off where is it
jaws it's not about the pet factor
you're keeping a monster for a pet so
you want to show up you're gonna look
cool like a villain in your super lair
you have a shark in your house how cool
is that
this feels very familiar do I go with
the choice that would be people would be
clear to have or that's better to show
off
[Applause]
I think I just I feel like I just heard
more from Spencer I heard more about why
jaws would be cool to have in your house
and I think all I really heard for koi
was like the bedding factor which after
they're not a model anymore
with jaws yeah Charlie what are your
thoughts a lot of instructions that go
on make a Falkor a monster monsters
lovely he's looks terrifying he's all
flesh shark is so hard aquariums of
entire - I just feel like you still get
the cute and cuddly out of your pet so I
take I take I'm I have been transported
into Andy signore's Jer and I face a
decision those many weeks ago and I have
to say sitting in this chair the
Impractical 'ti of the gremlins is a pet
versus the awesomeness of something to
put in a tank and show people has won me
over
yes
[Applause]
someone average length episode of movie
fights
I want to thank today's awesome boys on
yo Charlie Feldman Spencer Jake Gilbert
thank you guys for joining us I hope you
come back and fight Spencer E or
championship rain has begun gun it's
another win under the belt get ready I
think there's gonna be a lot more like
these two coming for you coming on easy
you're sweating me so I thank you guys
for coming and thank you guys for
watching thank you for watching live on
YouTube thank you for watching and
commenting and subscribing and if you're
not thank you for coming back and
enjoying the show we will be back next
week not live we're gonna bring you our
all-star panel from San Diego comic-con
but two weeks from today we'll be back
here live Andy we'll be back with a
brand new panel of fighters fighting
everything movie-related out I hope it's
as ridiculous as this episode thank you
guys so much for watching see you next
time
[Music]